did no one come to save me just because
they missed me
i've loved playing captain jack so much
are you able to see this
oh we see you johnny and so did fans at
world's end has made nearly 1 billion
dollars at the box office not bad
considering at the time it was the most
expensive movie ever made with a budget
of 200 million dollars
i've been doing a pirate movie most of
my adult life and it's been a fantastic
fantastic you know group of people to
work with well i was 25 when i started
on it and you know i'm 30 now i had no
idea we would be making
uh three movies the beginning of three
they trek to find oh captain jack
he's in davy john's locker
and
that's a very unpleasant place to be
you're in davy jones locker captain
i know that
for this scene all the actors wore
wetsuits under their costumes because
the water was near freezing temperatures
leave your people alone for just a
minute look what happens everything's
gone to pot redeeming qualities of
captain jack i would say you know the
level of
irreverence um irresponsibility he's the
the the bouncing ball that it would be
fun to be that he can just sort of do
stuff and get away with it the immortal
captain sparrow who i like that
in one of the most perfectly cast rolls
of all time captain jack's dad shows up
fancy that keith was amazing
keith was incredible he came in and did
and and just kind of you know
swept everyone off their feet
although it's kind of intriguing to me
to see the whole operation go down and
what goes on the enormous size of it and
it reminded me of my stage
for orlando bloom and kyra knightley's
characters will and elizabeth the movie
finally delivered their long-awaited
nuptials making it the pirate wedding to
end all pirate weddings
it was quite hard work learning all of
the uh the sword routines and stuff and
particularly with dialogue and to cut
and the whole playing the uh the moments
of romance but we actually really
enjoyed it and keira was fantastic um
with a sword and doing the whole thing
she
seems to be able to do it all it's been
great to play a girl who's slightly
stronger i always think that's quite
good in these kind of kids films to have
those sort of female characters um and i
enjoy doing the fight scene so that's
that's been good that would never have
worked out between us
keep telling yourself that darling
for the movie's big premiere the
franchise came back to where it all
started at the happiest place on earth
not ready to hang up his hat just yet
depp went on to star in two more sequels
i reckon i'll take jack with me forever
you know i reckon he'll he'll always be
there you know
always be somewhat accessible
[Music]
you